and back to school means back to
homework and for many it also means back
to doing homework assignments on the
internet for the bus that's true last
minute that's what i did but if students
don't have internet or insufficient
connectivity their home or their
homework can suffer it's a gap one
former nfl player wants to close take a
look
they call it the homework gap it's
created when school-aged children don't
have enough or any internet access to
complete their assignments at home i
think now more than ever kids need to be
connected to the internet
at one point in time it was a luxury if
you had the internet
great if you did not that was okay but
that's no longer the case it's a
necessity it's integrated into every
aspect of our lives in the classroom is
no exception black hispanic and lower
income homes are affected the most
malcolm mitchell former nfl player is on
a mission to get kids connected i'll
share one which is acp affordable
connectivity program
and those who are eligible for this
program would receive a 30 subsidy to go
towards their internet bill
this is huge for some families because
it would make the internet free and for
all families it would reduce the price
substantially to learn more go to
cox.com
digital equity
a huge tip right there save some money
it's officially back to school time here
in the valley so this week